c'est un carrefour névralgique de
l'ouest de montréal chaque jour près de
80 mille voitures et camions circulent
dans le secteur de l'échangeur saint
pierre construits dans les années 60 il
a fait l'objet de nombreux travaux de
réfection fil des années il devra
maintenant être reconstruit et convient
pas newquay bio n'a ni aux
automobilistes ni aux piétons ni ou
cyclistes cet axe routier est situé
entre dorval et l'échangeur turcot il a
toujours été très fréquentée et pour les
piétons et les cyclistes qui transitent
ou l'échangeur il y a un important enjeu
de sécurité qui trop compliqué parce que
avoir beaucoup de voitures
vraiment
du monde ne dit pas avec le chenal entre
2011 et 2015
4670 collisions sont survenues sur
l'échangeur il y a eu sept morts parmi
ces accidents quatre sont impliqués des
cyclistes et des piétons la mairesse de
l'arrondissement réclame des changements
depuis des années se fait déjà huit ans
qu'on en parle puisqu'elle joue citoyens
ça sent l'envié ça s'en vient mais là au
moins je pense que le ministère des
transports nous y coûte une consultation
publique se tiendra ce soir le ministère
des transports analyse différents
concepts et veut entendre les
préoccupations des populations
mais les différents groupes de pression
et les spécialistes concernés ont une
demande claire que l'échangeur soir bâti
différemment sans modifier me falloir
concilier le transport routier qui est
important dans ce secteur le avec les
enjeux tout aussi important des
déplacements des populations locales le
ministère des transports du québec
considère que l'échangeur saint-pierre
est arrivé à la fin de sa vie utile mais
ne sait pas combien coûtera sa
reconstruction de plus les chances et
des travaux n'est pas connue pour le
moment ici qui me permettra du canada
montréal